hello welcome everyone to this joint OB
and scrutiny committee I am councelor
James cast
and I'm chairing the meeting today may I
first remind you of some domestic
Arrangements if you are attending the
meeting to speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you may be asked
to leave please ensure mobile phones and
laptops are on
silent additionally we will be using EV
voting for this meeting on the modern.
goov
app the council members of the public
and the Press May record film photograph
or broadcast this meeting when the
public and press are not lawfully
excluded if you are in intending to do
so please inform the committee
clerk if you hear the fire alarm please
leave the building immediately via the
fire exits and make your way to the
assembly point on the Ipswich toown
football ground follow the signs
directing you to the fire exits each end
of the floor do not enter the
atrium ground floor area or walkways
that is if you are in the atrium at the
time of the alarm follow the signs to
the nearest fire exit use the stairs not
the lifts and do not reenter the
building until you're told it's safe to
do
so okay thank you very much um so
attending this um meeting today we have
um councilor eor burn standing in for um
councelor Carter and councelor winch
thank you um officers we have um Amma
anwi
J could you just say your name sorry
I thank you and um you are the corporate
manager for Housing
Solutions um David
White the corporate manager for housing
transformation Rebecca
Ward housing strategy and policy
officer Holly Brett
corporate corporate manager for the
council's
companies um Robert FS housing enabling
officer thank you and we have Jan
Robinson and Alysia Norman the our
officers to help us so um thank you very
much I'll move to the
agenda so um do we have apologies for
absence
please thank you chair we have apologies
from councelor Piper and we have Council
of Pratt substituting this one thank you
thank you very
much um the second part to receive
Declarations of pecuniary other
registerable or non-reg interests by
members um councelor
Smith I have a dispensation from the
monitoring officer to take part today oh
okay could you um could the
um could you just sort of give us a
little bit of background on that please
yes so um all members at the start of
each um year after the election are
granted dispensation by the monitoring
officer if they're um social housing
tenants or um private sector landlords
that is to enable them to stay in for
these type of items um where it doesn't
actually directly affect their financial
or their wellbeing
oh okay thank you very much
um and um I should also then um declare
an interest as a um
landlord um thank you and don't take
that dispensation councelor
Wyman okay thank you councelor
Carter yeah thank you is that everyone
yeah thanks a lot um so then item three
is to confirm the minutes of the meeting
held on the 18th of September
2023 um I wasn't at that meeting um do
we have any issues with the accuracy of
those
minutes no could I have a proposal for
those minutes
please councelor Smith and um a second
is that councelor Wyman thank
you and um I'll ask the um officer to
conduct the electronic vote please thank
you chair members that vote is now in
progress what you call
it
that's coun to the pr
yes um my computer's still not um
booting up for some reason so um can I
just vote in favor please thank
you councilor
Riley however I to V
against thank you chair so that makes
seven votes for one against and four
abstentions that's carried okay thank
you so we've confirmed those minutes
thank you
everyone so um item four to receive
notifications of petitions in accordance
with the council's petition scheme none
received chair item five questions by
the public n received item six questions
by counselors none received chair thank
you very much so now we get on to the um
the main part of the meeting which is um
item 7 J
2321 which is the annual review of The
Joint homes and housing strategy so um
if I could invite councelor eburn to
introduce the report to committee
please thank you very much chair and
good morning everybody um today we've
got the annual update of the joint homes
and housing strategy for you to consider
and in the absence of councilor Richard
winch who's the mids member for um
housing and property I'm happy to
introduce this um for your scrutiny
today um in March 2019 members of all
political parties unanimously agreed the
adoption of the first joint homes and
housing strategy this strategy commits
us to be open and transparent providing
information on how we are performing
against the Strategic aims set out
within the strategy so as part of
adoption a commitment was made to report
back to overview and scrutiny committee
for an annual review an update to
members this is the fourth annual update
of the progress against the strategy and
today I ask that members review the
contents of this report and appendices
along with verbal contributions scrutiny
should also focus on the Strategic aims
and the progress with delivery and
you'll see that the report is dated
October 2022 but the um delivery plan is
obviously an update from that and is at
its most recent um time as in O this
year October
2023 um Rebecca Ward our housing straty
policy officer who responsibility for
the analysis of performance and
monitoring of the strategy will provide
you with a presentation to take you
through this and show the progress today
and future actions planned um as the
chair said um in in support we've also
got um of five officers including
Rebecca which Holly Amma David and
Robert and I'd be happy to um answer any
questions as well and and support those
officers but obviously as I'm not the
housing um portfolio holder likely that
I would take those questions away if
needs be but um please let me know if
there's anything you would like us to
follow up um on this thank you very much
chair and I'll say over to Rebecca thank
you
good morning councilors um I'm Rebecca
Ward housing strategy and policy officer
and I'm responsible for monitoring The
Joint homes and housing strategy and its
delivery
plan this presentation will provide you
with more detail and context around the
joint homes and housing strategy
focusing on what has been achieved in
the 12 month since this strategy was
last at the Joint overview and scrutiny
committee um what is currently in
progress and what actions officers will
be prioritizing in the coming year to
further our Collective progress towards
achieving the vision and the Strategic
aims of the
strategy I want to mention at this point
that in previous years this this review
has looked at both the joint homes and
housing strategy and the homelessness
reduction and rough sleeping strategy
but this year we'll be focusing solely
on the homes and housing strategy the
reason for this is that the homelessness
strategy is a statutory do document and
a new version has been developed this
year and will be be presented to this
committee at the November meeting to
start its journey to approval and
publication um in previous reviews of
this strategy by The Joint overview and
scrutiny committee we've taken questions
as we go um so I'll pause at the end of
each slide for questions before moving
on to the
next okay okay so I'm going to start
with some basic information about the
strategy and how it's
structured it is not a statutory
requirement to have a housing strategy
but this strategy was produced to
provide focus and should show ongoing
commitment to meet and address the
housing challenges across the
district the strategy document is
supported and underpinned by a
comprehensive delivery plan this sets
out what actions will be taken to work
towards achieving the Strategic aims set
out in the
strategy each action in the deliver plan
has an action owner who is responsible
for progress and for providing updates
each action has a Target date to ensure
that progress remains on
track action owners within the delivery
plan are from many different departments
within the councils as this slide shows
the strategy and delivery plan is not
just concerned with Council housing but
all housing within the
districts okay okay so moving on to some
background and
context The Joint homes and housing
strategy was adopted following
endorsement by both councils in March
2019 originally with a lifespan of 5
Years From 2019 to
2024 the strategy has one vision and
nine strategic
aims and as already stated the strategy
is supported by a comprehensive delivery
plan which sets out the work that will
be undertaken to achieve the strategic
aims of the
strategy who is responsible for that
work and what the target date for
completion
is the strategy commits us to being
truthful and transparent and to provide
information on how we're performing
against our delivery
plan therefore as part of adopting the
strategy a commitment was made to report
back to the overview and scrutiny
committee for annual reviews which is
why we're here
today the original strategy reached the
midpoint of its five-year lifespan in
September
the world has changed significantly
since the strategy was published and a
decision was made to review refresh
refocus and relaunch The Joint homes and
housing strategy in 2022 to ensure that
it better reflected and included the new
policy priorities that had emerged since
2019 therefore in 2022 work was
undertaken under the steer of SLT and
with the awareness of portfolio holders
to refresh the joint homes and housing
strategy the vision our residents live
in affordable and high quality homes
that enable them to build settled safe
and healthy lives within sustainable and
thriving communities and the Strategic
aims of the original strategy were not
changed they continued to be relevant
and reflective of The council's Wider
priorities so they remained as they
were the time frame was removed and
replaced with a date published this was
to better reflect that the strategy is
an Ever evolving document rather than
with a fixed start and end
point all references and data within the
strategy document were updated to ensure
that only the most relevant information
underpinned the
strategy and anything obsolete was
removed further detail was added to each
strategic aim to clearly show what had
been achieved since
2019 what was Curr being worked on and
what would be targeted
next work was also undertaken to refocus
the delivery plan to include the new and
emerging themes that were not around in
2019 when the original delivery plan was
written the document was comprehensively
streamlined by removing actions that had
become business as
usual time scales and Target dates were
tightened so that the document became
less vague and more
targeted more thought was given to what
success would look like for every action
within the delivery plan this was to Aid
monitoring and to ensure Clarity of when
an action can be marked as
complete all these changes were made
under the steer of SLT and under the
delegated powers of the director for
housing and cabinet members for housing
and this work was presented to and was
well received by The Joint overview and
scrutiny Committee in
2022 so to bring this presentation back
to this year and what has happened since
the two documents were refreshed and
refocused in
2022 in
2023 the delivery plan is monitored on a
quarterly basis by myself updates ass
sort from action owners in terms of
narrative status and any issues with
achieving the target
date the quarterly updates from action
owners feed into a quarterly update by
myself to the housing program
board a broad overview is provided to
the board and any delays or issues are
highlighted for further discussion with
all the right officers in
attendance in July of this year we held
a review meeting to look collaboratively
at the delivery plan and every action
individually at this
meeting um actions were archived if
they'd become business as usual or had
been
superseded actions were amended where
new priorities or guidelines had emerged
or to become
smarter and new actions were added to
better reflect current projects and
Ambitions an engagement exercise with
members is to be planned for
2024 to ensure that members are involved
in the review process I'll speak again
about this later in the presentation but
we are conscious that the local
political landscape has changed and we
need to ensure that the current
administrations have a chance to shape
the strategy in time for its next annual
review in
2024 we also need to ensure that the
priorities of the corporate plan refresh
are reflected in the
strategy okay so figures around the
delivery plan and progress made this
year as of October 2022 there were 62
actions in the delivery
plan steady progress has been made
throughout the year on completion of
these
actions after the review meeting in July
2023 30 of the actions were marked as
complete 15 of these have become
business as usual eight were projects
that had been completed five were
superseded and two actions were
Amalgamated with other
actions these 30 completed actions have
not been transferred to the new October
2023 version of the delivery plan this
new version of the delivery plan is the
version we'll be working to in the
coming year and it has 41 actions 32 of
these are in progress actions and nine
are new actions added this
year
okay I'm not going to move on to look at
each of the nine strategic AIMS in turn
to look at what has been achieved in the
past 12 months what is in progress and
what actions will be targeted in the
coming 12 months so starting with
strategic aim one which is the housing
market functions effectively providing
homes which are as affordable as
possible to meet the needs of residents
and support the local
economy in terms of achievements we have
have embedded the pre-application
process and reviewed its
Effectiveness continue to keep evidence
on stored sites updated to help resolve
blockages and delays to
development work is ongoing on the
adoption of the joint local plan part
one following it being declared Sound by
the planning inspectors in September of
this
year determining whether and how the
council can identify and bring forward
land to increase the supply of
self-build plots in the
districts within the coming years will
be focusing on increasing the proportion
of new homes delivered by the councils
which exceed minimum environmental
standards and are in line with the
council's design guide specification and
a target for this is to be set following
the publication of the new housing
revenue account business
plan success in these actions will
result in an increased an increase in
Quality Homes within the districts which
will contribute positively to meeting
housing
needs I'll just ask a question question
then councelor Wyman um I just wonder
where it says um determine whether and
how the council can identify and bring
forward land to increase the supply of
self build plots um what can we what
tools do we have and how do we go about
something like that
please uh thank uh thank you thank you
counselors um essentially um invite
Holly to jump in when I go wrong here
but it's it's around what land do we
have that is developable and suitable
for self-build plots and what are the
issues which would be involved um with
us bringing them forward because in
order to be a suitable self-build plot
we need to be able to demonstrate that
the the the plots can be served by
suitable infrastructure so there is a
question of what forward funding would
be required in order to enable us to
bring those plots forward for a for for
a planning permission so um to me those
are the questions that we need to be um
working through in order to determine um
what we can do in terms of our our our
land um noting that we do have a limited
supply of our own
land thank you um yeah so it's purely
counil owned land it's not looking at
any other private land or land available
well the um I think it comes up on the
next slide but the joint local plan and
sets out a positive um approach to
supporting self-build so if developers
wish to um bring forward self-build
plots themselves the planning system
with our policies Allied to the National
um the national framework is is geared
towards supporting self-build
development as well so it's not just us
but this action is about what we can do
with our with our land okay thank you
councelor
Wyman thank you chair um it was a part
it was the first part of the in progress
part which is adopt within the joint
local plan clear policies and direction
to all involved with development how are
you going to do
that how I've read the Jo sorry I've
read The Joint local plan and there are
elements in there but what concerns me
generally is the is the sort of lack of
coordination really between what our
planning policy is going to look like or
looks like now and how are we going to
actually Implement that
policy um that that's a difficult one
for us Tom on to stay without any
without any planning colleagues
colleagues with us but certainly with um
the the joint local plan has been found
sound um by by the inspectors it will be
put forward to members for adoption and
then planning decision should be taken
in accordance with that with that
framework
um councelor Pierce P Pearson
sorry thank you sorry sorry can I let
councilor eburn just come in there
because I think that's following the
previous question yeah thank you chair
I'm happy to take that away and um talk
to Cabinet colleagues um both in babber
and mids suffk to follow that one up
just to um in terms of you know the
relationship between what we're looking
at here for um housing and what's in the
joint local
plan thank you counc rean you I I I
suspect you can understand my concern
that there is often elements or silos of
energy going off and we aren't really
talking to ourselves as a as a business
to integrate a solution that works
within the planning system to facilitate
those social homes and at the same time
make sure that we're working with our
planning colleagues to free up the land
available the land that should be
available for those things to happen
absolutely and as officer said it's a
it's a planning policy point that um we
need to now coordinate with so I'll
follow that
up thank you councilor
Pearson thank you um there's a lot of
reference right the way through the
document about uh to affordable
housing is there a definition in this
context of affordable
housing I think that definitions of
affordable housing has set out in a
number of places I think the simplest
the simplest point to start with is is
with the planning definitions um which I
can send you send you um a reference to
the uh National planning policy
framework and and where it's defined in
there um and it defines a wide range of
types of affordable housing um you would
be heard of be familiar with concepts of
affordable rent social rent shared
ownership discount Market sale there's a
broad spectrum but certainly when when I
talk about affordable housing when I
think about affordable housing in the
context um of this strategy that would
be what I would be
thinking sorry I didn't quite follow
you'd be using the naal is that that
would be the simplest place in terms of
one one
[Music]
definition so that's the definition
that's used for this document thank you
thank you councilor
Carter uh yes apologies if I'm going to
steal someone else's question but um
based on looking increase B High self
build plots in this chamber on a
previous on meeting regarding housing we
discussed about the compulsory
purchasing of second housing or houses
that were not currently being used and
it was discussed about purchasing these
properties and using them to fill gaps
in the
our in our Market in for our um
residents yet it's not in a progress
report not being looked at or discussed
that has that thought has that been lost
or was that did I dream this
discussion previous
years I think you might be talking about
empty
homes right yeah that's a quite a long
process before we can even attempt to
cely purchase properties and so we're in
the progress of the officers contacting
owners bringing properties back into use
we to work with owners first rather than
go to enforcement and before we can even
get to compul purchase we're going to
have to go to the Secretary State to get
permission so we have to show that we've
taken all the necessary steps used all
the tools that we have in our kit in
order to get these properties back into
use before we go to purchase but what we
do do is we definitely work with owners
and we link them up with our Central
suffet leting service where we can see
we can R those properties back to
residents at lha plus 10% so that's
where we are at the moment in terms of
having any progress report we're not
there yet it's not something that was
envisaged when we had the policy but
it's something that we can certainly
look
at thank you very much um councelor
Jameson thank you chair um your next
Target is to increase the proportion of
new homes which exceed minimum
environmental standards uh so what are
we doing about our current
stock um so uh as part of the kind of
ongoing transformation of council
housing through uh the Building Services
transformation program um that is the
main point of that that program is to
obviously ensure that our Council
housing stock is uh you know meeting the
standards that are required of us by the
regulator um so there there are other
actions throughout the um strategy that
that will incorporate that but but also
our business as usual work um so so one
of the things that we are doing within
the next few months is a um targeted D
sorry a targeted stock condition survey
um we're going to be surveying um 50% of
our Council home owned homes in the
first year to um identify what work is
actually required because our
information that we've got is limited at
the moment um and then once we've got
that information um obviously we will
then be continuing with the other 50%
because the regulator expects us to have
100% stock condition data on all of our
properties um as I'm sure you would
expect us to as well um and uh we will
then be looking at what um what leverage
we've got within our H business plan
what our priorities need to be within
the the money of that um to enable us to
be able to deliver on those you know
those improvements that are required um
but yeah there is I can assure you a lot
lots of things going on uh in terms of
improving services to our current
tenants
sorry councelor
Smith uh thanks chair um I might have
just missed in what you said about
collecting data did did you say there
was a time scale on that yeah so we um
we have a limited amount of data already
so we've got about um 80% of our what we
what class of stock condition data
um uh so we're missing about 20% of it
um so what we need is to get even more
comprehensive data and obviously
complete it 100% of it um hopefully
within the next four years yeah um so
we're hoping to have at least 50% done
in the first year the the what we've
been doing in the past is kind of we've
been working along um guidelines of for
example you know cloning of properties
and things like that which isn't best
practice um so looking at similar
properties within a street and going
you're all the same well that's not the
case is it that that person's kitchen
may be a lot lot younger than that
person's kitchen for example um so uh
and the regulator has made it quite
clear in the new regulations that are
about to come out and so as part of the
the quality standard um that we need to
know you know we need to be able to
demonstrate that we know the stock
quality that we've got um and also that
we're using that information to
determine our maintenance programs our
investments programs um and uh but and
also who are who are living in those
homes as well um and determining the uh
you know the support that we're
providing to those tenants so um yes we
we're hoping to get 50% done to give us
a kind of a good idea of of the
investment that's needed in our stock so
that we can plan that out and then we'll
be using our own in-house surveyors to
continue with the with the remaining
50% that's a decision at the moment that
could change it could all be up for
debate I'm not I'm not 100% but is that
okay yeah thank you councelor McLaren
are you waiting to ask thank thank
you thank you
chair as a member of the health scrutiny
committee I am interested in the second
half of that aim which is about
supporting the local economy and the
reason I say that is that I've heard
some very public disturbing reports in
the last three months from the dental
service Pharmacy services and social
care there is a chronic recruitment
problem to this area uh in addition suff
college and suff university are
developing two new courses for one for
dental technicians another for pharmacy
technicians so my two questions are what
do we presently offer in terms of
housing when essential workers are
recruited to the area and what could we
offer students and the colleges to uh
who would be ultimately employed locally
by the NHS and Social
Services thank
you um hi right um we're currently in
discussion with our partners across s
about what the offer is I think what we
need to now down is what we mean by
essential worker so everyone has
different definitions I think it's going
out to those different key part partners
and saying what do you require what do
you need you know where is the demand
coming from and then looking at how we
meet that apply because it's a bigger
picture it's something that's an ongoing
discussion at the moment about how we
support different um Employers in terms
of Health social care so that we attract
those key skills into the districts so
that's currently an ongoing conversation
um where we are at the moment is not
quite clear because obviously you got to
get everyone on board and then we've got
to look at how we deliver to that and in
terms of students that's not something
that's been on our radar at the moment
but we can certainly take that away and
have a look at that and have a broader
discussion on
it just clarify so at the moment there
is an offer of some accommodation there
is an offer of accommodation but we are
having conversations with Health social
care about what the offer could be what
we do as as suffk to deliver on
that thank you chair thank you very much
um I'll go to councelor row and then
councelor Pratt but I will say there's
nine of these slides to come so um there
will be plenty of opportunities to ask
questions in between other slides but um
yeah please councelor
row um I this is one of the questions I
wanted to ask today anyway um so you've
been talking about
data and I know it's on page two it says
about col collect the right sort of data
of evidence to ensure we put in sound
vids for all new funding sources related
to housing as they become available um
there's the social housing
decarbonization fund which has another
round opening in
November um and kind because of not
having the data we've missed the
previous two rounds so um I'm as this as
the report was put together in October
22 are we now in a position to apply for
it next or are we still needing to have
we fail to colate that data to apply for
the
round yeah so we we have got enough data
to be a to enable us to uh effectively
hopefully effectively apply for that um
next round of funding so that's the I
think it's the 2.2 uh wave of of
decarbon decarbonization funding um so
yeah we are in the process of providing
that information for our worst
performing properties through EPC so EPC
is something that we actually do have
quite a good record of um so so yeah
that that will be what we're using for
that um and we we did um actually have a
meeting about that at the end of last
week um because it's one of those Wicked
issues that we we're trying to get
underneath um but but yes we we are
progressing with
that thank you very much councelor
Pratt yeah um relates to the second part
of the aim really um meeting the needs
of residents and supporting the local
economy um well just a I know this is
question but just a little bit of
background I think you know if um people
are
spending significant proportions of
their
incomes on rent on on
mortgages um because housing is
unaffordable it chokes the rest of the
economy it's a bonanza for land owners
and developers but it doesn't help
stimulate the economy and I think that
that's a bit of a pipe dream um so my
question is is are affordable
housing um Target going to be affordable
to individuals based on a median income
for a person under the age of
30 or that kind of younger kind of age
range in the
district thank
you um councelor I think I think you're
you're you're alluding to the different
and I think it's effectively what
councelor Pearson was saying as well is
is the difference between um the
definition of affordable housing and
housing
affordability um
um and and and there is a difference as
you have alluded to in terms of the
specific um the specific uh sort of
household circumstances that you're
referring to there I I I couldn't answer
that question off the top of my head I
would have to go away go away and look
at it um but certainly we are we are
meeting um within the the definitions of
affordable housing we are meeting our
delivery targets to deliver sufficient
affordable homes um but something which
uh
something which we are going to be
looking into which isn't isn't reflected
in this report but um is is seeking to
um uh the section 106 properties that we
secure which may or may not be taken on
by the council may be taken on by um by
taken on by RPS looking to link that um
nail it back down to um local housing
allowance levels there um social rents
are obviously a benefit if we can secure
them the social rent properties are
rarely deliverable without public
subsidy thank you very much um I'll just
ask um Rebecca Ward to carry on um with
aim two I
think okay moving on to strategic aim
two which is there is a wide and varied
choice of good quality sustainable homes
of different sizes types and tenures to
meet the needs of a wide range of
different
households in in terms of achievements
we have continued to provide advice and
encouragement to community-led housing
schemes with the objective of delivering
new affordable housing this is not a
quick route to affordable housing but
provides a valuable
contribution we have reviewed and
updated our local connection criteria to
enable some of the affordable homes
secured through section 106 agreements
to be prioritized for those of the local
connection work is progressing on
adopting an affordable housing
supplementary planning document this is
linked to the adoption of the joint
local
plan um work is progressing on producing
an enhanced affordable housing stock
data base to support housing enabling
and development
decisions and work is progressing on
ensuring efficient use of the council's
housing stock by creating a cohesive
plan considering occupancy levels Trends
and bab and mids suffk District
council's housing stock to address
overcrowding and meeting the needs of
larger families alongside the creation
of a new scheme to incentivize support
and encourage tenants to
downsize within the coming year we'll
also be focusing on producing a brief to
clarify in commission further research
into the role of the private rented
sector in preventing and relieving
homelessness in Babor and mid suffk this
will help direct future activity for
Central suff lettings and to inform
wider housing enabling
decisions councelor grandon
please thank you Mr Clair um I've got
two questions um in the paper on this um
you talk about air source heating
program for uh Council
houses um can you tell me whether this
is sort of retr fitting on existing
stock or um ensuring that it's happening
in any new stock that we have and the
costs of doing this um against the cost
of traditional um so that's my first
question
please so we're going to tag team this
one because Holly will talk about the
new new stock and I'll talk about the
existing stock so um yes we are looking
to try and um increase the range of um
renewable uh forms of of you know energy
heating um and uh on our existing
Council properties and and that's partly
around um what council Ro was talking
about in terms of the decarbonization
funding so trying to get more funding to
be able to deliver that sort of stuff um
air source heat pumps are not great in
isolation you need to have a fully
insulated property um and it's also it's
also going to be kind of a level of
Engagement required to the people that
are living in those homes because um you
know it's it's a different way of life
almost uh in terms of what we're all
used to going to the firmat tur out
turning it down that doesn't happen uh
with with kind of air source seat pumps
so if it does it means they're no longer
working efficiently and then you know
there's also the added um issue of
trying to address fuel poverty so um you
know which will impact on on our on our
social housing tenant CS particularly um
so yes there's work going on in the
background around all of that um but as
I say the biggest challenge I think
we're going to have once we found the
money is um is the engagement with our
existing residents to ensure that that
the systems are being used um in the
most efficient uh way
so so it's not so that's being done
through grants that are available rather
than it from it coming from our own well
we have to match fund any grants so
right yeah you don't just get the grant
without putting some money up yourself
so um yeah there is going to be uh some
Financial
um require in my view I think we need to
work out whether that's the best view of
best best use of our
resources just a few houses that is um
that is debate councelor grandon but I
think that second question was
supplementary and you still have another
question to ask thank you yes I do thank
you um
the how are you planning to
encourage um tenants to
downsize how is that being done um what
resources are being offered to to such
tenants I think we all agree that that's
very necessary um because that will free
up houses for other people along the
chain how is B and mid staf are planning
to do this so there is currently a
policy in development um which uh the
corporate manager ATT tenancy Services
is is currently constructing
um it's not an easy task to encourage
somebody to downsize from from personal
experience it is you know people that
have lived in their their Council homes
for a number of years
um are probably uh you know likely to be
you know of uh fry and an old age so
just the thought of having to move is
going to be very very difficult to them
um so the sorts of things that we put
we're putting in or Pro proposing to put
in place are things like Financial
incentives um but also uh because
obviously moving isn't cheap for anybody
um but also um looking at what support
we can actually offer um tenants in
terms of you know physical support
um so you know it could be from uh
helping somebody to actually go on to
you know get an application onto the
housing register to downsize because
that can be a barrier for some people um
yeah there's a there's a range of
different things that we're considering
at the moment and what we've done is
we've looked at what others are offering
in the area um other housing
associations housing associations have
been doing this for years and and you
know always have a pot of money aside
every year to to throw at tenants to to
encourage them to downsize um it I still
from my personal experience don't find
it to be as successful as we probably
all like it to be but what we already do
um as you may or may not know is we do
also provide high priority on the
housing register for people who are
giving up those homes so if you are in a
three bed and you're giving and you only
you're wanting a one-bedroom property
you already get the highest banding so
you're on on band a for that um if you
if you're giving up one bedroom uh you
get ban B so you are you know we are
already doing that as part of our
allocations policy um so are we planning
to be
proactive in this encouragement or is it
just people be Senter a message to say
you know this is available but are or
are we being proactive and
encouraging movement so we would love to
be more proactive in all of our tency
Management Services however that you
know we we're very reactive at the
moment because of the limitations that
we have on resources and having to deal
with the issues that were in front of us
but um but yes we will be talking about
it at opportunities that you know that
present themselves to us um and
publicizing it as widely as we possibly
can that's about as proactive as I think
we'll be able to be thank you thank you
councelor
Smith thank you chair um you've
partially answered my question because I
was going to ask about downsizing as
well um and I agree with councilor
grandon that it's a it's great that
you're going to be offering these
incentives um I you say you get priority
banding if you're downsizing but I'm
aware of cases where the system the
gateway to Home Choice system doesn't
pick up that that that's what the uh
tenant wants to do um
so are you aware of such cases and how
satisfied are you with gateway to Home
Choice in
general I I'll answer that I think
what's happened in the past I know about
some of these cases where applicants
haven't answered the questions correctly
so they don't actually indicate that
they're looking to downsize so the
system will automatically give them a
banding as per but we do have officers
that will go through the application and
if applicants think that we've got it
wrong they can come back to us and we're
quite quick on getting on that to say
right what's what's the issue when we
review that so terms of go time Choice
quite satisfied with what it does I mean
on the main part there is a lot of
manual intervention as in it
automatically accesses but before it
goes live officers do go through it and
it is depending on what applicant put on
their form so sometimes people don't
necess indicate correctly that they're
looking to downsize therefore it will
just we can only go by what people tell
us thank you is there a specific
question on the form that says are you
wanting to downsize
it does ask you what the reasons are for
what you wanting to downsize so but
sometimes people do miss that um so
that's easy that's an easy mistake to
make but we will come back quite quickly
the officers are quite good at going
through it and going oh is that right is
not that not right and then they do have
lots of interactions of applicant before
the application does go live if it is
missed we're pretty quick on resolving
it thank
you thank you very much councelor
Carter um yes I'm glad gateway to Home
Choice brought up are you aware of the
many issues that residents or applicants
have with Gateway H CH which has
previously been raised uh part of it is
is it's wonderful that he puts in a form
but it's not so easy to fit life in a
form we have residents who are applying
for if a for example disabled husband
able family wanting to get a house
especially for your husband to sleep
downstairs whereas if they were unable
to do it they had to go through quite a
few Hoops to get round and it uh it was
very difficult to actually find so it's
gateway
to hosis is a wonderful form doesn't
make it very clear and when it comes to
as well applying for
property uh when you do have re
questions you can search for Council
properties and you can search for other
but it doesn't make it clear the
differences between the two we've had
people gone through got housed of a uh
agency which doesn't have the same
protection as a counsil
property
and Something's Happened and we've ended
up having to go through the whole list
again trying to house them again
separately I just want it's been
discussed previously about bringing the
system in house rather than gateway to
Home Choice
yet we haven't gone any further so I'm
trying to work out why we still using
gateway to Home Choice which is why
aren't we looking at to keeping it going
inh house and a second question combined
to
this regards
the we made a comment previously about
looking at uh getting to know our
residents and making the property
suitable for them
well when it comes
to maintenance of these
properties um
repairs personal situation having to get
a repair or so keeping it a stock
suitable to attendant whereas you have a
repair for example a adaptive well a
shower door opening with hand rails for
the resident to get in and being told
that we don't offer showers with open
doors we do sliding doors if you want a
SL Open Door you need to get an OT which
could take longer time so in the inter
room being replaced with a sliding door
and in my personal case a sliding door
with a glass panel blocking off the
handrose to get into the
shower so why aren't we looking at
bringing in household bringing in
inhouse
ot to actually keep the stock viable to
Residence rather telling the person yes
you're a council tenant yes this is a
council property but we can't fix your
thing without you having to go for a
different
hoop I will pick up both questions I'll
do the first one um we are doing a
health chef of gateway to Home Choice um
when I arrived here last year we just
signed a new contract to be a Gateway
Home Choice for the next couple of years
however in saying that being part of
gateway to Home Choice allows presidents
have a lot of choice about moving across
the suffer District if they say want to
and also it allows us to work
collaboratively as district and borrow
councils where we have an issue if
another Bor has an issue someone's
feeling domestic violence or violence or
needs a certain type of property then we
can assist each other with that that's
one of the things we obviously share the
cost of the system as well across the
seven Partners as well so I think that
has to be taken into consideration as
well um because there's powering numbers
we work together colle collectively in
terms of improvements on the system in
terms of it not being easy we are
looking at how we manage people who need
specialist accommodation so we'll to
adapted doingit how we advertise them
you know um what's available as well
we're looking at that in terms of
delivery but I think the other issue is
it
is we can review that in terms of how
hard it is for people to get their
situations across because it's a complex
situation when you're dealing with
a household and they have different
varying needs and then it's always
trying to find within our stock what is
going to meet their needs how how
adaptable that can be and also how
possible that is because I think what
you were talking about there with that
particular household is that you'd need
a parlor house with two rooms on the
ground two usually we have two living
rooms on the ground floor that would
considering that situation but it it can
be difficult and we we recognize it as
an issue and I think going forward when
we're looking at our delivery of new
homes what we're bringing on board we're
looking at making sure that we've got
enough specialist provision to meet the
needs of our residents I think that's in
consideration but also I'm trying to
think what you the rest of the question
but I think we are reviewing the Gateway
ter choice we're seeing how beneficial
it is to us as districts are we getting
from the Gateway what we expected what
are the issues what the problems how can
that be resolved and we can always take
that back to the project board which I'm
part of and look at the issues and iron
those out and definitely we need to
streamline how people make an
application and the information they put
across as well to make it easy for them
I
think what it is is I know from a
officer perspective we we may test the
system sometimes I think that's great
because we understand how it's intended
to be used we probably could benefit
from getting some user use from our
residents sometimes when we're having
new systems put in and having new forms
um designed for us to make sure that
it's okay for residents I've been in
that situation where I think a form is
great it's wonderful and then having
spoken to someone using it going well
actually I'm dyslexic I need more time
and it times out for me it's too quick
so we need to do a lot of constant
feedback from residents in that sense so
we'll look at that but in terms of the
repair side I'll have to we'll have to
take that back to our colleagues in
Building Services to get you some
answers for that but in question to
think about why don't we have an
in-house OT that's actually one of the
conversations we've been having about
would we be better of having an inh
inhouse resource you know to deal with
the needs of our residents because it's
becoming a an issue and actually I have
worked in other load where you had had
in house housing OTS and it makes a
world of difference because it's just
it's not about just existing tenants but
new tenants coming in to see whether or
not our stock can be adapted for their
needs so it's definitely something that
we're looking at in terms of resources
going
forward thank you and that be a good one
for debate um councelor Carter I think
councelor Jameson and C then councelor
grandon we we do need to push through
because we need to have enough time for
good quality debate so please um
questions as um brief as possible but um
obviously please still ask your
questions well thanks um you said that
we're on track to enhance the data we
hold on our housing stock so just a
cutle of questions on that you also
answer the last question earlier you
said we got 80% of the stock data at the
moment so why don't we why do we not
already have data on our housing stock
what's been the problem probably we've
had hairs in stock for a long while so
why haven't we got the data and if we've
got 80% of the stock data why is it
going to take four years to get the rest
of
it so I'll answer this as best as I can
because I haven't been here um for for
as long as uh some of our other
colleagues my understanding is is that
we have a limited stock information for
80% of our stock um what we've actually
been doing over the last few years is
we've been carrying out stock condition
surveys inhouse using our own inhouse
surveyors but to a to a limited um level
so somebody used the term stock
condition light which I've never ever
heard of um but that's what apparently
we've been doing um so we've got stock
condition data but as you as you quite
rightly said that's probably taking us a
very long time to gather that
information we have two stock condition
surveyors across both districts um so it
takes a long time to get around the you
know nearly 7,000 properties that we've
got and it's a bit like painting The
Seven Bridge by the time we've visited
the first one um and visited the last
one we' then got to go back because
actually the stock could then be uh the
stock condition could have then changed
or failed um so that's why we're
planning on getting a contractor in to
get 50% of them done within you know
within 12 months I think it is uh I
don't know the full details of the plan
because it's not in my service area but
I think it's around 50% in 12 months um
to give us that kind of better Baseline
that we've currently
got thank you um councelor grandon
please I'm happy to ask my question
later if that would be all right thank
you very much councelor
Pratt yeah very quick question um what
have we done so far to advise and
encourage community-led um housing
schemes and the formation of clts um and
where can this information be
found um we we have
um we have been commissioning Community
Action suffk who go out and do a lot of
promotional work um on um community-led
housing and we ourselves go out and and
speak to discuss with with parishes who
show an interest in in community-led
housing um we're currently working with
with a number of parishes which is in my
inbox
here we are currently working with uh
actively working with one two three four
five six um parishes who have clts
established Community Land trusts um
we've also identified a further five in
babber and a further six in miduk which
we are trying to encourage to go out and
um deliver um more community-led housing
um I believe there is information on our
website and there's also information
available from the easn community homes
Hub which we also contribute
to thank you and we go back to the
presentation
please moving on to strategic aim three
um homelessness is prevented and our
services provide positive and planned
interventions this strategic aim links
directly to the homelessness reduction
and R sleeping strategy 2019 to 2024
which is a statutary document a new
strategy is being developed this year
ready for the expiry of the current
version in
2024 um the new draft strategy and
delivery plan will be presented to this
Committee in November to start its
journey to approval and
publication in terms of other
achievements in the past year we have
supported the recommissioning of housing
related Support Services in partnership
with other suff
authorities we have created a program of
pre-tenancy assessment and training for
new tenants designed to help tenants
manage their properties and their own
finances and as part of the preparation
for the writing of the new strategy we
have comprehensively reviewed the
current um strategy and have fed that
the findings of that review into the
draft strategy um work for the first
half of the coming year will be focused
on the new strategy um and as I said it
will be presented this committee at the
November meeting to start its Journey
do you want me to carry on to the next
one as we're not going to take any yeah
I don't I don't see any questions so
please yeah just keep going and um when
we when we get questions we'll just stop
for those
thanks right strategic aim four which is
babber in mids is an effective social
landlord known for delivering quality
services in terms of achievements this
year we have co-created developed and
launched a 10 engagement strategy which
enables tenants to hold babber and mids
District councils to account on
performance in areas that were important
to them and in a way that suits
them we have built on the work of the
complaints task force to learn lessons
continually improve and to provide
Clarity around areas of
focus and we have implemented a rolling
um tenant satisfaction
meth methodology to drive business
change within housing and to comply with
the regulator's tenant satisfaction
measures
work is progressing on establishing
compliance with the social housing
regulations including consumer standards
and building safety regulations to
ensure that bab and mid suffk is a is a
compliant landlord and to ensure that
tenants are able to see how we are
performing against the
standards um determining the feasibility
and cost of a range of retrofit Energy
Efficiency measures to improve
environmental performance of our housing
stock reduce operating costs in enhance
the customer experience and support
vulnerable
tenants work is also progressing on Pro
producing an updated housing revenue
account business plan provides the
organization with a clear and costed
housing
service um Building Services is
undergoing a full diagnostic assessment
to ensure that the service is in an
optimized position to meet the
requirements of the building safety act
and to contribute to meeting climate
emergency
objectives within the coming year we'll
also be focusing on ensuring we quality
repairs and planned work service by
making sure our contractors respond to
Works orders in a timely manner as set
out in their contract key performance
indicators and our tency
agreements success in these actions will
result in compliance with the social
housing Regulators requirements and
contribute towards delivering a modern
landlord service that meets the current
and future needs of our
tenants councelor
scarf uh thank you yeah um on the paper
copy um it talks about we aim to bring
forward Innovative Redevelopment
opportunities for redundant and
underused sheltered accommodation um
just wanted to get some sort of clarity
on that we told earlier in the document
that the number of people over 65 is
going to drastically increase over the
next 20 years um so this redundant or
underused Shel accom shelter
accommodation is it in locations
geographically which are difficult to
fill or is it in towns because see a
dilemma if we're encouraging people to U
downsize uh in into that might be the
right kind of accommodation and are we
moving too fast or is it purely it's in
the wrong place and nobody wants to live
there thank you I'll pick this one up um
it is because it's in the wrong place um
these generally are the properties that
go through Choice based lettings where
we don't get any bids on them at all and
it's the locality that seems to be the
issue also it might not be the right
type of accommodation for our residents
and what people need and I think later
on we're going to talk about the older
person strategy and that's linked into
it it's us basically doing the right
thing as a landlord reviewing our stock
profile is it fit for purpose does it
meet the needs of our residents do we
need to be doing something different do
we need to deliver something different
for that particular cohort of residents
so that's what we're looking at it's
it's not going to be something that's
going to happen overnight it's going to
take some time um obviously if things
change and then there's an inas demand
for those properties then we would
relook at it at the moment we're just
exploring what our options
are thank you councelor
Riley yeah that's better thank you Mr
chairman so here we are Target next
please uh we are holding Contra we shall
be holding contractors to account are
you suggesting that we don't hold
contractors to account at the
moment
I would say that there has been um some
of our contractors have been not managed
as as well as they should have been um
not held to account in terms of the uh
contracts that we have in place um and I
think some of the contracts that we've
got in place don't really cover what it
is that we need to cover so there is
work going on at the moment to review
all of those contracts all of the
contractors um it's also down to kind of
contract management and having the
resources to effectively contract manage
um um in in the repair service alone
there's there's probably around 40
contract different contracts um that all
need to be managed effectively and
that's being done by people as part of
their day job rather than their day job
um so I think that that speaks to why
some of those contracts haven't been
managed very well in the past but that
is all um yeah looking to change as part
of that um whole redesign of Building
Services thank you would you like a
supplementary uh yes indeed yes please
so when I last inquired about this I was
told that we were check we aim to check
one in three contracts completed we were
managing one in six this was about 10
years ago and my real question is
this people who don't deliver on their
contracts in other words take money from
the
residents you know without doing the
work which is a a form of theft do we do
we find them do we punish them do we
Blacklist them do we in other words you
know do we penalize them in any way or
is there a moral hazard that they have a
better chance of getting away with
things than by doing things so it's all
down to what the terms of the contract
say so as to whether or not we can
penalize contractors um and that is part
of the problem is that our contracts in
the past haven't had those kind of
performance metrics within them to turn
around and say if you don't meet X then
we will withhold y for example um the
other issue around uh inspections of you
know I couldn't tell you I don't know
what the percentage of um post work
inspections is being currently carried
out on all of our various different
contracts um but the uh my I suspect
it's not as many as we would like due to
the resource um that that
takes we are now doing audits as well on
our gas um and electrical safety um uh
works so um that's that's something
that's recently been introduced and is a
requirement of the building safety
standards as well that we we can make
sure that our um health and safety
obligations are being carried out so
that's an improvement from where we
were thank you and I'll go to councelor
Jamon thank you again U you tenant
engagement survey is it going to be
purely um by post and online or are we
actually going to go out and knock on
people's doors and speak to them in
person and see their see their problems
so the ten engagement strategy was
launched November last year um and was
approved by our cabinet um last year um
in the forming of that we um we did uh
engage with tenants for for to ask them
how they they want that strategy to ban
out um and we uh did that in a variety
of different ways we did it by post we
did it online um and we ended up with um
just short of 1200 tenants views coming
back to us um to tell us so we've got
quite a good um that was you know an
excellent response rate um and we've got
quite a good understanding of what it is
that our tenants how that our tenants
want to engage with us and as you can
imagine there's a variety of different
ways any good tenant engagement strategy
will also provide a variety of different
ways so in short yes we'll be doing it
all so so we have been out and knocked
on people's doors yeah we have um what
we call Community Action days um so
these are areas where there is a
particular
um need either identified by W members
or um by tenants themselves we're also
using the data that we're collecting
from the tenant satisfaction measures
one of the questions in the measures
that we have to ask is that is around
your landlord's contribution to your
neighborhood um and where we've not
scored very well in that area where
people have told us that they're
dissatisfied we've gone to Target those
people and gone out and done a community
action day knocked on their doors you
know you know engaged with them um in
their own
community
thank you councelor Smith thanks chair
I've got two questions that are both
relevant to this slide if that's okay um
firstly back to the contractors has
there been any discussion about the
possibility of taking back any of the
contracts in housee um you know a
general maintenance anything like that
yeah so we do have a DLo set up um here
which is a direct labor organization um
which basically means that we try to do
the majority of our um kind of General
day-to-day maintenance ourselves in
house which is why we've got a Trad team
Etc um there is a I think as part of the
transformation of Building Services and
as I say it's not my specific area so
I'll try and answer it as best as I can
um the the view is is that we definitely
want to be bringing more stuff in house
um so that we've got more control and
more uh you know quality over over that
those Services however in the you know
the school of is that you will never
have a fully inhouse um repair service
because it's all around the risk
involved in the organization so if we
were to have our own gas contractors for
example roofing contractors you know we
U we would need to contract those types
of works out because it's about drisking
the organization so um yeah so there
there'll be there will always be an a
level of contractors but um we would be
looking as as much as possible to keep
um most of it in house
that's great thank you and um completely
different the tenant no the complaints
task force um what what is what is the
complaints task force please yeah so the
complaints task force um was set up in
about
20 2020 I think it was um just before I
arrived we have relaunched it the
complaints task force meets quarterly um
it is it has a tenant that sits on the
task Force um it has our portfolio
holders on the task force um our
director and service managers and what
we basically do is we look at the last
quarter's performance in terms of um
complaints but also the themes and the
lessons that we've learned um these are
then published on our website to enable
um uh our residents to to be able to see
that we are trying to uh you know
address complaints in a timely manner
comply with the housing ombudsman's code
of conduct but also that we're learning
from our complaints which is the most
important thing to for me it's not about
numbers you know we could have thousands
of complaints a year if we if you know
that's not the problem for me the
problem is is what are we doing on the
back of that feedback so that's very
much what the complaints task force is
set up to do it's to to hold us to
account as as you know a council and
officers um that we are doing stuff to
learn and change making
changes thank you councilor McLaren
please thank you chair um I just like to
refer to the complaints about antisocial
behavior
um from my experience it seems to be a
bit confusing for tenants as to where
that complaint goes and that's recent
experience what information when a
tenant takes on a teny are we are they
given that sort of information to um
guide them when they have a a problem
with antisocial Behavior thank you uh
yeah as part of the sign up process we
do uh was part of the not the sign up
process but we do a welcome visit with
all tenants um that's usually I say a
visit it's sometimes it's over the phone
it depends on the needs of the tenant
and obviously the resources that we've
got available um and that at that point
we will talk through um those types of
you know all the conditions within the
tency agreement that we feel are
relevant um we also provide all of our
tenants when they sign up with a video
um which is basically our tenant um
tenant managers explaining to them
around the the terms of their tency and
what to do in certain scenarios um but
yes we anex social behavior complaint
and complaint are two different things
and and that is a challenge for us
sometimes um an antisocial Behavior
complaint is actually a request for
service whereas a complaint is about our
in action or lack of service so um yeah
so you could complain about us not
handling your anti social Behavior
complaint proper properly um but an
antisocial Behavior complaint isn't
counted as a complaint um you know in
terms of the Blain Stars
Wars got to say it it's not very clear
though we kind of yeah we kind of did
the determination of what a complaint is
is based on what the housing ombudsman's
code of guidance say so um and
antisocial behavior isn't a complaint in
in the terms of the anti of the housing
ombudsman's code of guidance they can
only complain about the service not that
their neighbors are misbehaving for
example yeah thank you chair so now we
have a question from councelor gron and
then Council of Pratt but after that um
I'm thinking that we probably need a
comfort break for the length of the
meeting's been going on and I think
officers might need a um small break
from being grilled um but um so um what
I'll do is we'll try and do that by um
52 and then reconvene at 11: so we'll
just go councelor grandon and then we'll
go councelor
Pratt thank you uh this isn't the
question I was going to ask before
that's still going to be later um yes on
on the paper version of the report um
you say you're going to review internet
usage among
tenants um and develop measures to
enable an increase internet
usage how are you going to do that
especially you know you you've said
throughout report how our um demographic
is is
aging and obviously with that there
comes lack of finance and lack of um
understanding um the in the internet so
how how are you going to do that please
um so we do already asked the question
within the tenant satisfaction measures
survey um and we can say with 95%
confidence that 80% of our tenants have
access to online services um and and
access them regularly um so I don't
don't do that by internet no no no we we
so we actually ask those surveys 80% by
telephone and 20% online um and that and
that's because of uh you know that that
that's a a good methodology that we've
been told by our contractors but yes 80%
of um confidently we can say 80% of our
tenants have access to the internet
already um I take your point about an
aging population but I think um you know
as we all age we are all going to be
that aging population and we're going to
be able to use the internet so I think
it's you know maybe that people that are
in that bracket at the moment have have
difficulty some of the stuff we've done
we've done a digital skills um roll out
in some of our sheltered schemes so um
we did I think we did have four um four
sessions with sheltered housing tenants
in areas that told us that they wanted
to know more um and we we worked with an
external provider to provide kind of
basic online and and computer skills
training there could be an opportunity
to do more of that um that that was kind
of we worked in conjunction with our
customer operations team um because
digital kind of inclusion falls under
falls under their Emit and is not just
focused on our tenants obviously it's
focused on all residents so um yeah so
uh I'm not 100% sure what else we're
doing as a as a c or as councils to
encourage that but um yeah for me it's
also about providing better online
services for our tenants specifically
they don't have great online services at
the moment um they can't report a repair
and select their own appointment for
example which you would expect to be
able to do in this day and age um so
that's something that we're looking at
um in in the very short term actually to
improve uh by looking at a new job
management system um to enable customers
to be able to selfs serve a lot more
rather than just sending in a form that
goes to an inbox that somebody then has
to ree into a system call the customer
back you know if they do ask them when
they would like the appointment etc etc
you know that sounds a very good idea
and that sounds like something we should
have been doing a long time ago yes yes
we we need the service to be able to
back that up though as well because it's
all fair enough people booking
appointments if they can't book them
until six months time then that's that's
another that's another issue thank you
thank you councelor Pratt more of an
observation I'll save it for the debate
thank you okay thank you very much so um
yeah if we um if we go for a five minute
break but that's a um Target not an
absolute so if you do need longer please
don't feel that you can't take longer
but if we aim for
about 3 minutes past 11 to come
back yeah thank
you
thank you very much and um we'll return
to the meeting now um we're on um aim
four have we um done this one we're
going on to aim five aren't we so if if
you could tell us a bit about aim five
y so strategic aim five is homes are in
high quality sustainable environments
served by jobs and Community facilities
appropriate Green Space effective
transport links and other necessary
infrastructure in terms of achievements
in the past year we have adopted our
updated Community infrastructure Levy
spending framework and adopted an
infrastructure funding statement we have
embedded ensuring delivery of sufficient
infrastructure to meet requirements
arising from new developments this work
has become business as
usual we have adopted the new design
guide specification which sets out a
clear and ambitious design framework
which captures characteristics in design
that we will aim to adopt generally in
our projects and further aspirational
objectives that we hope to incorporate
where it's it is suitable viable and
beneficial work is progressing on
updating the published infrastructure
delivery plan by working with Partners
to assess infrastructure needs and
delivery
mechanisms work is progressing on
establishing a collaborative plan that
considers viability capacity and
expertise to investigate in stalling
electric vehicle charging points to
serve existing Council houses within the
coming year we'll also be focusing on
utilizing the housing Revenue accounts
Capital environment Improvement budget
and other Associated funding through the
greater places better spaces initiative
to prioritize measures which support the
health and well-being of our residents
encourage social interaction Empower
tenants residents and communities and
other other partners and positively
impact on reducing carbon
emissions please carry
on okay moving on to strategic aim six
which is best uses made of private
sector land and private accommodation
across the districts in terms of
achievements in the past year we have
promoted and supported Energy Efficiency
in homes by targeting FNG energy
performance rated properties in the
private rented sector this project was
in partnership with the suffk wide
minimum Energy Efficiency efficiency
standards Consortium properties were
identified and action was taken the
continuation of this project has become
business as usual for the private sector
housing
team we have assessed potential demand
to support the various Refugee and
Asylum Seeker accommodation needs which
provided much needed Clarity on the way
forward to meet increased housing needs
this was working a partners ship with
suff County
Council work is progressing on
establishing a landlords Forum to advise
and assist landlords in respect of their
legal responsibilities Grant
availability and Universal Credit to
build better relationships and increase
access to the private rented
sector work is also progressing on
reviewing our approach to houses in
multiple occupation and houses in
multiple occupation licensing with the
aim of developing a targeted approach to
engaging with a broader range of
properties within the coming year we'll
also be focusing on reviewing the
current system of Grants to private
landlords to maximize opportunities to
improve the health and well-being of
residents and the Energy Efficiency of
homes we'll also be focusing on taking
active part in the suffk wide private
rented sector Pathfinder program to
improve conditions for
tenants councilor Wyman please could two
really quick questions one um hmos are
hmos a aailable to the council as
operators question two I'll gra still my
mind um private landlords do we
scrutinize and investigate the quality
of private landlords prior to our
working with
them I I'll answer these ones um we do
have hmos available to ask through
Central suff lettings the team have been
doing some really good work with some
developers and landlords in terms of
bringing them online to use for our of
residents who require them so yes we do
have them available and in terms of
scrutinizing landlords before we work
with
them most landlords we will have for to
them to complete and that would include
the fit and proper person statement as
well and we will look to see if we have
taken any enforcement action against
them in the past um obviously we're now
part of the um Pathfinder private rented
Pathfinder with the wir suff
um local authorities at the moment the
initiative that's going on and we're
looking at how we work all together
collaboratively in terms of the
intelligence that we gather on landlords
across suffk so that we can use that
between all of us so that we can see if
someone's operating in ipswitch whether
they're operating in East suffk if they
come to B mid suff we'll be able to
touch on that intelligence and look at
how they're behaving what enforcement
action has been taken in the past so we
look at that so we will look at their
behaviors before we work with them quick
supplemental um sorry um is that
something which we've been doing more
recently or is that a long this is the
scrutinization of landlords really
because my anecdotal experience is that
we are sometimes working with landlords
that have really a pooring track records
in other districts where they're
bringing their sort of um poor ways of
operation into into our
district that would be a more recent
thing because at the moment we wouldn't
have that Intel that information we will
of course touch Bas of our colleagues in
the other districts we work quite
closely together and quite well as a
private sector renting teams but you're
absolutely right at the moment sometimes
we do fly blind so hopefully with this
initiative we'll bringing some more
collaborative working where we share
our um local Intelligence on the way
landlords behave obviously there will be
some landlords that people will know of
a lot better than other that's more
anecdotal rather than having the
intelligence there to work on
that
thank you councelor
scarf thank you yeah well another
question really regarding Central soic
lettings um say that we're working with
investors and private landlords on new
um housing developments and conversions
um one of the current problems for
private landlords especially small
private landlords is the affordability
of being a landlord
um and and that in itself is is a is
becoming a real issue for for landlords
um do we have have any conversations
through Central subject LS or through
our housing team with landlords who wish
to get out of the sector I.E sell their
property and with a view to the council
perhaps taking on their property or a
range of properties that they offer as
part of our uh program of
housing we have been approached by
landlords in the past and we continue to
be approach it will depend whether or
not it fits within our plans whether or
not that
meets our requirements as well because
obviously we have our own standards and
it depends what we've got available I
think at the moment we spent all our
Acquisitions money for this financial
year so it's looking at going forward do
these properties meet our needs in terms
of also future in terms of doing repairs
work does it sit in because a lot of our
stock is very similar and we have
standards that we keep to so it can be
difficult but when do they do approach
we do look at it and we do consider it
to see whether or not it's something
that we would want to take on
[Music]
thank you very much could we continue
please okay moving on to strategic aim
seven people live in vibrant and
well-connected communities and homes and
communities continue to meet the
changing needs of
residents in terms of achievements this
year we have continued to develop the
integrated neighborhood team to improve
the way housing Health and Care Services
are delivered with and for local people
work has been progress ing on
commissioning an older people's homes
development strategy which will include
analysis of housing needs for older and
vulnerable people and will focus on mix
type numbers and spatial distribution
the analysis will also include
downsizing opportunities and will
consider alternatives to Extra Care
housing um work is also progressing on
carrying out a health check on our
current lettings and allocation policy
to ensure that the current Arrangements
continue to meet the needs of the
councils and our
residents in the coming year will also
be focusing on bringing forward
Innovative Redevelopment opportunities
for redundant and underused sheltered
accommodation and completing an update
the accommodation needs assessment for
gypsies Travelers traveling Jo people
and boat dwellers in order to inform the
forthcoming Jo joint local plan part
two councelor
grandon thank
you in um the printed paper it says
achieved reviewed our housing
allocations policy to consider how it
meets the needs of older and vulnerable
applicants and throughout the paper as
as I mentioned earlier you do talk about
our our older
population
um but I'm finding that this actually
isn't working in practice it's all very
well providing us with this very nice
paper
but some of the things that you're
saying here don't seem to be happening
in
practice so you know I I have um a
situation with a resident that I've
brought to U some of your team's um
attention um where this older and um
disabled uh
tenant simply wanted to moved to um
ipswitch away from his property in
babber and every obstacle was put in his
way um can you tell me uh um as this is
the question part of our
meeting how you're trying
to sort up re review this kind of situ
situation um you know I felt as if I had
everything blocked in trying to make
this happen
um I ended up having to involve um
senior uh counselors and go around a
different process which shouldn't have
to
happen how can you tell me and
assure
counselors that the situ ation my
resident and um us as counselors
experience shouldn't happen what
remedies are you trying to do to make
what's in this paper actually happen in
practice because certainly I didn't find
that to be the
case I'll take this one thank you we can
only control properties within our
district which is bayber msuk we can't
control what happens in iwi so if
residents want to move to another
District they are beholden to what that
district and they will have their own
priorities as well so I think that's
where the difficulties stands from yes
we're part of the Gateway so sometimes
within the Gateway properties do become
available cross District that people can
bid on but it is very difficult we can't
control what happens if a resident wants
to move to another District but actually
it was the lack of help and
understanding and support that was given
by our department
that was the main
problem so my question to you is what
would you like us to do in that sense
what would you like to happen right PE
treat people as
individuals um I mean now this person is
having to um a swap has been found now
this person's having to wait 42 days I
think we've got to be quite careful not
to be too specific about what's going on
here in general and I do wonder if this
might be better handled by email but why
why for example is a 42 day wait because
that's the legislation the legislation
says it has to be 42 days we can't
circumvent that and actually I think the
suggestion was in that particular was to
pursue a mutual exchange because you're
more in control in that sense you get to
choose exactly where you want to be you
see that property and you can do it
within your own time and if he didn't
want to go through it that's so those
are the other options that people caners
series a social you always have those
options in terms of mut exchange as well
because when you're talking about
crossborder moving you are beholden to
the other districts we can't force them
the same way they problem lack of help
and
understanding um and finding blocks
within the department right I'm quite
happy to not this specific situation
what I'm concerned about is we've got
this lovely paper saying these are our
objectives and aims but in actual fact
when it comes to it um you're not
carrying out in practice what you're
saying you're planning to do in your
paper councelor grandon I think there's
probably some sort of recommendation
proposal there for looking at how things
are done differently so maybe we'll um
just stop that there and we can talk
about that in debate um thank you very
much and we'll go to um councilor Pratt
thank you chairman
yeah just briefly one of my constituents
um had an experience um where they did a
mutual
exchange um and um the house that they
moved into wasn't of the quality and and
um you know it wasn't wasn't in the sort
of state that it should have been when
they moved in The Exchange took place it
was mediated online on a team's meeting
um I'm just wondering have we put
anything in place to assure that I don't
know buildings our buildings um Team um
or somebody goes in and checks that
these um accommodations are are suitable
before the exchange takes
place I I'll pick that one up we're
going to Institute what we call a good
to go process that will happen before
any exchanges happen even before someone
goes on the housing register so that we
check the um state of the property first
we make it very clear what their
responsibilities are as a tenant that
the repairs they need to be doing and
the repairs that we need to pick up as a
landlord that may have been reported or
have not been reported yet so going in
the future this wouldn't happen but what
should be happening is is that before a
mutri change happens there should be
some form of inspection of the property
by an officer to go around and have a
look around to check because with a
mutual exchange it's sight of SE in
essence so definitely that's an
unfortunate
situation well that sounds like a good
an improvement thank you I would just
add as well that a lot of that
virtuality was picked up during Co and
we've now started to move back to the
physical kind of inspections but we do
we do always encourage tenants to visit
those properties that they're looking to
exchange with various numbers of times
we don't have to be present when they do
that different times of the day all of
those sorts of things um yeah because
unfortunately in a mutual exchange
there's always a loser there's always
somebody who's got a worser property
than the other one
so thank you very much um next slide
please
right strategic aim eight everyone has a
suitable home and residents are able to
live as healthily safely independently
as possible within sustainable
communities in terms of achievements
this year we have continued to work with
Partners across the suffk system
including Health to further develop
measures to support vulnerable residents
during winter this work is now monitored
as part of the cost of living action
plan we have supported those living with
dementia and their carers to remain
active and engaged with a range of
dementia friendly activities and
opportunities we have collaborated with
our partners to establish social
prescribing schemes and non-medical
referral options to improve
well-being work is progressing on
implementing a program of upgrades to
heating systems in Council stock
replacing oil systems wherever possible
and prioritizing heat pumps where
appropriate um workers also progressing
on developing an early help Hub that
delivers effective coordinated multi-
agency interventions
and establishes a more strategic
approach to avoid service duplication
and reduce long-term service
costs workers also progressing on taking
forward measures to improve the
environmental performance of our housing
stock in order to reduce carbon
emissions meet National targets and to
contribute to corporate and countywide
climate emergency
objectives within the coming year we'll
also be focusing on ensuring health and
safe homes by beginning to carry out a
program of comprehensive stock condition
surveys of our housing stock over a
rolling four-year
period councelor Jameson please thank
you um considering the um issues we had
with
contractors uh recently What's um what's
been done up to now to meet the basic
maintenance
standards see on your thing about a
comprehensive stock condition under what
what um it's been done so far so do you
mean in terms of specifically
contractors that we've been using or
yeah I mean there's been issued in
contractors so a lot of Maintenance
hasn't been undertaken and I've wondered
what's what's going to happen now to
improve the maintenance yeah so um one
of the big things that we've done is
obviously we've terminated early a
contract um on our gas servicing side of
things gas and electrical servicing um
so we've actually had to bring in
because obviously we need contractors in
place and that's always very difficult
when you've got a contractor that isn't
performing needing to have another
contractor in place going through the
procurement exercise um so we have
managed to do that and we've got
intering contractors in place for those
for both Gas and Electric um uh and
whilst we are carrying out a full um far
procurement process um in terms of the
uh other contractors that we need to use
for sort of more gen generic day-to-day
repairs um that's all been done um
although it's not been done for through
the full procurement process we we're
needing to get contracts off of
Frameworks at the moment because
obviously you've got a need and we
haven't got the time um uh but the
contractor the contracts that we've got
in place are a lot better quality and
the management of those contracts is um
is a lot better than it has been in the
past so that that's what we are doing
we're very much focused on the contracts
and the contract management now where
was we you know before that wasn't
necessarily the case are we we are
actually keeping up with their basic
maintenance yes what we're also doing is
in terms of our backlog of repairs
because we do have a significant backlog
um we are putting out those jobs to um a
contractor to to get completed so that
our in-house teams can focus on the work
that we've actually got coming in
because as you can appreciate we can't
get we can't just can't get through the
work at the
moment thank you very much um number
nine
please okay strategic aim nine both
councils have strong relationships with
residents developers and other partners
that enable us to deliver housing
infrastructure and services effectively
and to innovate where appropriate in
terms of achievements this year we have
continued to maintain our stronger
relationship with homes England in order
to optimize the funding streams for
which we are
eligible we have worked collectively as
local authorities to support the
effective delivery of services in
relation to housing through the suffk
housing
board work is progressing on providing
support to Neighborhood planning groups
to create and make effective plans that
deliver housing that communities
want workers progressing on developing a
neighborhood strategy and policy setting
out how we will work with our tenants to
improve the areas they live utilizing
the greater places better spaces
initiative this will include reviewing
our approach to the management of
garages and setting targets for
improvement in satisfaction with the
neighborhood as a place to live within
the coming year we'll also be focusing
on developing an engagement plan with
members to holistically review the homes
and housing strategy to ensure it is
reflective of our current Administration
strategic priorities for housing in the
districts the form that this engagement
will take will be led by cabinet members
for housing and any feedback from the
overview and scrutiny committee
committee as to how we should proceed
with this exercise will also be taken
into
consideration councilor
mlen uh
um in relation to Neighborhood planning
groups what
um system are you going to use to um
communicate with Parish councils because
they're the ones who are the the
starting point for neighborhood planning
um my two I've got two but they're
already there but um there's a lot of
Parish councils I think would benefit
from some organized communication with
them as they consider neighborhood
planning thank
you and unfortunately again we don't
have a we don't have a planning officer
in the room so I think I'd have to take
take that one away and and come back to
you on that but certainly you know we
have a neighborhood plans officer who I
know he he engages with with Parish
councils all the time but I'll get to
come back and can I ask you please that
you keep the local Ward member involed
that you're doing that as well thank
you
thank you very much um a question from
me um and the portfolio holder for
finance might be best to answer this but
it might be quite obvious um is this
department paid for out of the HRA
account or the general fund please um
thank you chair yes it's it's um HRA and
um we are um there's obviously huge cost
pressures pressures within the HR at the
moment because of inflation um
particularly in terms of the work that's
um you know we talk about contractors
and um paying for you know obviously the
the goods as it were that one needs to
use to to do housing repairs and so on
so there's there's huge pressures um
currently within the HRA account and the
um we're expecting to see a 30-year
business plan for the HRA um in the next
couple of months which all members will
have a opportunity to to see um but I
think that will kind of bring home
the kind of scale of the of the task um
that we've got with very limited
resources and um offices mentioned
earlier about um potential funds that um
we can apply for from other sources um
which is fantastic but but as they've
also said we have to then match fund
those as well so um there is um great
pressure there sorry chair that's a
rather long answer no that was really
helpful thank you I think that was um
very useful for the committee um the
other question I had was um previously
we have got behind with things to um say
the least um gas safety checks and such
like um what checks have we brought in
now to make sure that that um people are
aware of where we are with that and we
can deal with them before it gets too
far behind or becomes a major
problem uh so yeah we are still
currently engaged with with the
regulator for social housing actually
got meeting today with them at 2:00 um
so we've been engaging on a monthly
basis to provide them with updates on
our progress um and um and obviously
there is also a weekly kind of tracker
that goes around to the portfolio
holders and senior members of staff to
ensure that we're on track and we we're
keeping up the momentum um we will never
be at 100% compliance just because of
the nature of what it is that we're
doing um but what we need to be in a
what we need to be in a place obvious
where um you know those that that we
know about those ones that we're not
going to get into in you know ahead of
time one of the things that we have put
in place is when we're applying for
injunctions to gain access to properties
we're actually applying for lifetime
injunctions so that means that um for
the next time that the gas service is
due we won't have to go back to court
we'll be able to rely on the same um the
same injunction um so that's something
that's quite novel actually and
something that um hasn't been done
before um but um yeah and the other
thing that we've we've introduced is um
as I say we're auditing um the
inspection process so again that
provides the regulator of assurance that
we're not just offloading our
responsibilities onto a contractor we're
actually taking uh initiative to make
sure that the services that are being
carried out are being carried out to the
standard that that they need to be
um yes and then what we've got to do to
get out of Regulation is we need to
provide the um regulator with third
party Assurance um that we are compliant
but not just that we're compliant but
that we've learned our lessons and we've
put play put um put taken steps to make
sure that that that doesn't happen again
and that we won't be non-compliant again
so that's the next phase thank you yeah
and I think it's important to note that
um part of the problem was not being
able to access properties to do checks
um which um is a very difficult position
and takes time to solve um counselor
eburn chff I I could just follow up on
that yes that is one of the the issues
is that you know the the teams have to
somebody has to let them in and someone
has to give them access to that home so
even if you're doing checks that are are
vital for the health and well-being of
that household in terms of gas safety
checks and so on if the householder
doesn't let them in you know and they
book an appointment or they and they
can't get in that is obviously an issue
and and but I think everyone's working
really hard to make that happen because
obviously we want to ensure that all our
tenants
are safe and secure in their homes um
and I think also from a a cabinet
perspective there's the issues that the
social Regulators um raised that we have
to um adhere to and ensure that we
comply with but there's also other areas
such as damp and mold where we've said
look while we're doing compliance on all
these issues please can we ensure that
every aspect of the of the health and
well-being within that um tenants home
is is looked at to ensure that as I say
they do have a a healthy safe and secure
home thank
you so um I don't believe there's any
further questions so can we go to yeah
then we'll go to debate councelor
Wyman I was heartened to see 4.15 in the
um in the overall program which was to
ex the engagement exercise with members
uh and then pushing that on through
cabinet how are we going to do this
what's the process
that's Up For Debate quite literally um
so we we'd like that to be discussed I
think as part of the debate now um and
we'll also obviously be led by our
portfolio holders cabinet members for
for housing as to how uh that they want
that you know they see that happening as
well um but we also want to involve um
you know not just yourselves but tenants
and residents in that process because
ultimately it's you know not doing to
people but bringing them along with
us thank you um councilor Carter I don't
know if you'll come up on the screen
because you've changed seat but um yes
apologies for playing musical chairs
yeah no no you're fine you're up there
thank you okay thank you um just say a
quick question we've mentioned regards
keeping W members involved I did wonder
what information we are currently
providing with our just new tenants
moving in but I know of some residents
in our social housing but not aware of
weren't aware which boundary they were
in weren't aware who they counselor
weren't able to find out from a website
what who their counselor
was um and trying to find out
information so what information do we
give it to our residents of our social
housing so I'd assume there's more
chance of them to need
a communication with the council and
there sometimes best communication is
with the ward member with the counselor
so what feedback are we given and what
uh when we move in or how are they
finding information out and what two-way
communication do we currently have what
can we go forward to improve them so uh
a big part of the new social housing
regulations which are currently out um
for consultation um we we have as an
organization or as organizations
responded to that consultation one of
the um standards that is changing it was
called the tenant involvement
empowerment standard is now called the
um transparency and influence um
standard or something along those that
sort of description so what we have
started to do and what the me the
measures that we've already started to
put in place is obviously the tenant
engagement strategy itself that we
launched last year um that's currently
that's going to be reviewed again in
November as part of its annual review um
and we're hoping to involve tenants in
that we've also increased the membership
to our tenant board our tenant board had
kind of was flailing should we say um
we've kind of revived that um and we've
now got five new tenant board members
we've increased the tenant engagement
officer by one so we've now got two
tenant engagement officers across both
districts so that's really really
important um my position was created uh
you know in January as well so that's
helped to drive tenant engagement um and
um yeah and and as I say what we are
doing is it's all about tenants being
able to hold their landlord to account
and I suppose in turn hold members to
account by um by what we're doing and
members being able to um uh you know be
assured that the officers are are doing
what we need to be doing um so we've
also started to publish um our
performance information it's on our
website it's read available now to
everybody um we also publish on a
monthly newsletter to over 4 and a half
thousand of our tenants that we've got
email addresses for um what our monthly
performance figures are um and we've
engaged with tenants already about what
is it that you want to know about so not
just what we've got to tell you but what
else do you want to know about um so
yeah we do lots and lots of Engagement
and hoping um well I'm not hoping I'm
assuring you that after the annual
review of the tenant engagement strategy
we'll be providing a or we'll be
publicizing a report that shows all of
the engagement work that we've done in
the last 12 months and kind of what
we're planning to do next
year thank you um counc
Pratt um just um just a quick question
are we are we allowed to um make
recommendations in this part let's um do
that in the debate um oh I thought we
were on to that sorry yeah sorry no we
we're still um we're still councelor
Riley yours a question we'll go through
to debate after councilor Riley's
question and then um I'll um I'll bring
you in two very quick questions um if we
go back to page 15 of the paper that's
come forward to us uh the very top our
key one of our key priorities is that
everyone has a suitable home and I
wonder how this is subject to the smart
framework the everyone um
all-encompassing U term and my second
thing
is I'm aware from um there are a number
of families who are larger than the
average or average than the median you
know uh how do we um look after
them okay I'll take this one um when we
say everyone I think we talk Prim about
our own tenants those in social housing
and private rented tenants because we
have a duty to make sure their homes are
meet certain requirements so we do that
because the landlords have certain
requirements on them as do we as a
landlord so that's what we mean by
everyone and we talk about that we do
offer assistance to private homeowners
around Energy Efficiency but then we
can't tell them what condition to keep
their properties in in that sense um and
the second
question larger families we're currently
reviewing what we do and it's definitely
something that we know that it's a a
growing issue I think it's been quite
difficult because we've had
what we've had in the planning pipeline
doesn't match what the current need is
at the moment so we're looking at how
we bring that together so that's where
the downsizing policy comes into play
we're also reviewing our housing stock
in terms of what we do have how we're
using them at the moment so but we are
looking at bringing in a policy about
dealing with larger households how we
rehouse them what opportunities they
have to move at the moment
councelor grandon are you waiting for a
question now or are you ready for
debate yeah thanks um I know that in it
switch there's um a large hotel with
families um from Broad in have we got
many um people who are either waiting
homes or in temporary accommodation that
are
um um what's the
word yeah refugees and Asylum Seekers
please we have one hotel in
baba um that has refugees in them Asylum
seeking refugees in them and it's mainly
singles and I think there's about one or
two families in there and there is a
plan for those households in terms of
what we can do to support we doing that
in conjunction with the Strategic
migration partnership so there is a plan
we did bid for some of the local
Authority housing fund we were
successful and across both districts
we're looking to deliver 24 properties
and that will be family side units from
two beds to four to deal with that to
deal with that adding
pressure thank
you thank you so we'll um now go into um
debate please I think we I think that's
been a really good quality questioning
session with good quality answers as
well there's been a lot of different
issues raised and um so with the debate
if we could sort of aim for um
recommendations as we go but OB
obviously say what you um feel on the
subject the um I think a few
things came up um in questioning um from
um different members and if you um if
you've asked a question that you think
leads to a recommendation please um let
us let us know in this stage um but um I
think
um for me there's there several
questions of resources which um we um
we've heard about the HRA account and
how difficult it is it's not just a case
of adding more resource it all has to be
it all has to add up at the um on the
balance sheet and um we can't spend
money we don't have it's it's very
difficult with the quite a well-off
general fund and an HRA that that
struggles but that's the way the
legislation um leaves it um we've talked
about the Gateway for Home Choice the
issues with application and
communication with that we've talked
about in-house occupational
therapists um the Community Action
suffer questionnaires with the the um
with the parish councils and um
stakeholders um for me one of the big
parts of this was downsizing and um how
um the tenants get across the message
that they want to um downsize because um
if we if we don't very clearly point out
they want to downsize they'll be seen as
adequately housed and um therefore it
won't be something that's given priority
and obviously it's something that we
really do want to support and get behind
because it solves the problem with the
existing stock that we have um of you
know getting people in the right right
houses um the um also we've we've
discussed um private tenants and how we
scrutinize them and how we um how we
look you know investigate them before
we're working with them but I'll I'll
open up to the um the floor of debate
and yeah I'm pleased to hear some
recommendations councelor
Jameson thank you chair um in the paper
there's a lot of talk about um a high
quality homes and social homes fit for
purpose but I'm sure all councilors
counselors here will be aware of tenants
who are living in awful conditions
within their um their Wards um houses
with damp mold no plaster on the walls
broken
kitchens um this is just as um examples
of people in my world I'm aware of and
um complaints are not dealt with in time
I've had a an old couple who would been
complaining about their ceiling that had
fallen in for two years and it may have
been fixed now but it wasn't the last
time I
checked and there's an audit that's
going to take up to four years to assess
the state of our homes so that's
residents living in these conditions
before they even we even get to find out
that they're living in those conditions
and it's before we so it's 4 years
before we can even start work so I don't
think that's that's not good enough I
don't think 4 years is I know we got
resource problems but four years is too
long so if you want a recommendation I
think that we need to recommend that
that foure time scale we've got to look
at ways to bring that fouryear time
scale for the audit um of our proper we
need to know the homes what the state of
our homes are if if and we can't have
residents sitting for four years in
awful G mold conditions because it's
going to come back and buy us and it's
going to cause you know if huge problems
if um that sort of information was to go
anywhere so yeah if you want a
recommendation we need to get that all
it time scale up to four years down
somehow thank you thank you so that
would be that the the stock condition
data is we don't find it acceptable that
it will take four years to um collect
that okay um if we um what would you
like me to um put that to the vote or
should we just go through at the end as
long as you're writing them down we
we'll go for at the end and we we'll
vote on them to make sure they the will
of the whole committee um councilor
pra thank you chair yeah um I I really
liked the fact that the strategy makes
um important connections between uh
housing and the economy
um which you know we we know that um the
quality of of our housing is is really
crucial and to ensuring people have a
healthy space or healthy environment to
live in and this affects uh the
contribution they're able to make to
society and to the economy as does the
affordability of their housing as well
if they're spending all their money on
on housing there's there's less money to
spend elsewhere um this affect
particularly affects the growth and
success of SE smmes and local businesses
in terms of the private um Market I feel
that we really um need to identify what
is really affordable um on the private
Market um we could uh sort of State this
against the the government's definition
of
affordable um so we we need to identify
um what is in my opinion what is ID what
is Affordable to a young person so it
could focus on a demographic of 30 and
below for example on a on a medium oh
sorry on a median income or or or a low
or just about a lower percentile
perhaps because these are the people who
are really struggling to afford homes
whether whether rent through renting or
or
buying um the mppf definition of
affordable housing states that
affordable housing is up up to and 0% of
the market value and I think that most
of us know in reality that this is just
unaffordable to most young people who
want to stay within their Village or or
town um within their support networks
and their
families I would like to propose a
recommendation that within any relevant
planning documents or spds that we
create an
additional definition based on local
metrics from our own districts that are
based on medium incomes or something
similar and relevant demographic data
now of course we need to have regard to
the mppf
definition um but but this could be used
to throw down a marker and at least
demonstrate to our communities that we
understand the difference between the
idea of
affordability that is told to us and the
reality that many people
experience
yeah I think um you've got a very good
point there and I think the way the our
planning system works with
them 35 or whatever percent affordable
homes means that several of the other
homes are unaffordable to private buyers
because to cover the cost of the smaller
homes they've not made houses in between
they've made big expensive ones to
absolutely maximize the profit on the
land and that might be um a bit more of
a planning department issue or a um you
know a a planning um policy issue but I
think yeah yeah I think you're um can I
just briefly add also to avoid confusion
with the npf's affordable housing
definition we could call this our
District's housing
affordability definition or metric as
well we we could just make that very
clear and
distinct yeah thank you councelor Wyman
and then councelor scarf thank you chair
first I'd like to say congratulations to
our our officers for putting forward a
really good presentation it was really
readable uh easy to go through and
thanks to all the effort that you've got
you've gone into I've dealt with one or
two offices over the last two three
months in relation to specific issues
and received pretty good support
actually so I wouldn't like to go away
and think that we don't value that
support um councelor Pratt made a really
good point on the affordability side
which I think is really really strong a
really strong point we need to bring
across um the thing to remember I think
is that we're dealing with fin out
Resources with huge demand and
inevitably there's some constriction
over how these resources are distributed
and we just need to take a pinch of
reality as to where a the money is going
to come from and B how we're going to
spend it in the most effective way
possible so I think inevitably there's a
certain amount of tension in relation to
how we do this job and in that way I
feel supportive of our officers in the
way they're trying to manage these
resources and at the same time
understand what you know I feel as a as
a ward member when people come to me
with a problem which seems as though we
you know we should have a solution for
it um I haven't got any of the
recommendations other than the fact I
find it's really important that we
integrate our sort of demand side issues
with our ability as a as a district
authority to enable sensible and and
well positioned development for our own
purposes in terms of social housing uh
and we need to sort of wean ourself off
you know affordable housing in in
inverted Commerce and housing
associations because housing
associations with respect not all but
some are trumped up private landlords
you know so we need to think about that
really closely and try and take some
level of control across all the services
that we provide whether it's repairs
whether it's finding the locations and
also managing our tenants expectations
um because it's really important so
that's that's my comments and
observations sh thank you very much
sorry councelor scarf but I've missed
councelor row out and he had his hand up
before you so I'll go to councilor
row um a bit on the previous point I
like I find the report quite useful to
and it's really good hearing how we are
learning lessons and are moving on from
some problems before um in my experience
elsewhere i' I've seen more kind of
traffic light type approach so instead
of just going um we're on target or
things are in progress there's a bit
things have been presented in a way
which is a bit easier to see quite where
we're doing well where kind of there are
difficulties
and where we are not at all achieving
what we should be so I was wondering so
the recommendation that I'd like to make
is for like going forward have a bit
more of and have a bit more of a traffic
light system for example which kind of
means it's easier easier for us to see
kind that where we're doing well and
where we're not um and also a bit
including the kind of risk in how much
we're going to achieve it or not because
there's some things where kind of we're
going to aim to achieve it but through
un kind of unknowns or various external
things there is a certain level of risk
and um again when looking at kind of
things like the delivery plan knowing a
bit of that risk um would be quite
useful and that's um in this document
you're saying or do you mean in reports
to
counselors the traffic light or the the
clearer reporting I mean like in this
report um the traffic I came up to this
recommendation because of in the report
it has the kind of achieved on track
thing but didn't have
anything it wasn't easy to see where
things could be improved so C traffic
light in this instance and for the
delivery plan kind of was where I
thought a kind of risk bit next to the
in progress bit could help but equally
being reasonably new to the council I
don't know all the documents I'll be
seeing going forward so recommendation
would be where appropriate for this and
other um documentation but I'm needing
to assess
it
yeah thank you chair um yeah I mean I
think it's obvious to councilors the
tremendous work that the department
overall is doing and it's a very long
journey um we've started from uh a base
point and clearly um we've made a lot of
improvements but there are also uh a lot
of further improvements uh to make um I
think I'd like to commend the reduced
number of action points in the plan
because it's always better to have a
sharper focus on a smaller number of
points and particularly welcome the new
ones that you've added to the plant
because I think they are entirely
relevant I think we do have to recognize
the tension um within the repair service
um because I think members should be a
last resort for tenants to come to I
think that tenants should be able to
come to the department first and
speaking as a member I've been involved
in a number of um issues which I find
surprising on the tenant repairs side so
I think that does lead us to conclusion
that there needs to be a a refocus by
perhaps the council or its portfolio
holders on housing and helping and
supporting the department through these
transitions so I think that might be one
recommendation uh a very clear Focus
because it's such an important part of
what babo and msab do um and in
regarding the members involvement
ongoing I think it's such a crucial area
you you've heard from a limited number
of members today but members when we
discuss things will often discuss tenant
issues housing issues ETC it's probably
one of our biggest mail bags so I think
as much involvement for the members
going forward looking at this subject
before the 2024 would be useful normally
we would say a task and finish panel or
members working group but actually I
think there should be open sessions with
members all invited so that we can all
make contributions uh towards that so
that perhaps the second recommendation
thank you very much um councilor McLaren
please thank you chair um I think I'd
like to
um say that for on this committee there
are many new members but I want to
recognize the hard work that that team
opposite have done uh over over the last
few
years um I I just appreciate all that
hard work and it's not easy with limited
resources so thank you very much but in
relation to say a
um
recommendation one of the things that
struck me when I was reading the report
was that the number of dwellings
withstanding planning
permission uh and in that is 5,000 at
the or when the report was it's 5,000
outstanding dwellings that we need we
are desperate for housing and uh what I
would like to see perhaps from um the
committee see from the uh Chief planning
officer is a current situation on how
many houses have not been built and
could he give us some reasons for the
delayed
construction thank you
so would they be um Council houses or
well it's it's the whole there's all
these planning applications that have
been approved and I was on the planning
committee uh they've been approved and
there's no development at all okay thank
you councelor grandon
please thank you chair um yes I agree
with um much that councelor scarf um
said
excuse me in his comments um I'd also
like to say you know that
I
sorry recognize it is a very difficult
task uh that the team has to deal with
it's almost a sort of sanus task because
you know as soon as you do someone's um
repair someone's property you know
there'll be something else that'll
spring up maybe even in the same
property that that needs dealing with
you know we all know if we have a
property ourselves that we live in that
um maintenance and dealing with admin
regarding your home is an ongoing thing
so if you're having to deal with
thousands of them um it's going to be an
impossible task to always get it right
and on
time um but on the sort of problem that
I had
with my my particular tenant that um I
highlighted had a problem I wonder
whether something like
um developing a system where if an older
or vulnerable person has a
problem um that they are they come
straight to you and they're kind of
highlighted in the system and kind of
handheld a bit so so they can be
navigated through the
system um
proactively where um rather than
explained All the Rules and Things um
rather than given
barriers if the if it can be
reversed and that you as a team or an
individual is allocated to help such
people in a proactive positive way um to
help them through the
system um rather than explaining why
things can't be
done um and that might
then a sort of slight change in attitude
if you like I don't know if that
something like that could be proposed
and um and carried out
please thank thank you councilor
Carter and then um I think um we do need
time to go through these recommendations
that have been placed and just get get
it exactly right councelor Smith They'll
Come to you as well after councilor
Carter um thank you uh firstly wanted to
um commend and second second some of the
points made across the chamber
especially FR is from Council Pratt BR
uh
w w wman
that's the one yeah and scarf so sorry
about that um I've got written there
somewhere um yes um I would like to say
that having sat in this chamber before
and made same suggestions it
be like to see some insurances about
what's said today is followed forward
and not having to be raised again the
following year so I'd like to see some
recommend has being put in I'd like to
see him forward so that's
report wonderful I'd like to have some
Assurance it's definitely going to be
followed through
um one thing I wanted to point out is
regarding councilor Scar's point about
the ward members should be probably the
last people shouldn't need relan on
board members well as a council tenant I
personally would like to see a degree of
control when I make a report have SE
some feedback because currently feed it
in the form and that goes nowhere you
don't get a reply um and you don't know
where it is if we had some sort of
format some sort of on the website where
you can actually enter your teny number
and then you can see where you've raised
report have it SE notified that it's
been looked at by an officer or somebody
and then get some feedback and actually
see it's definitely like you would in ad
doct when you raise a uh doctor's note
you can go on the system and you can see
it's been looked at a doctor and it's
been sent to somebody else just have
some degree of actually knowing it's
going somewhere some degree you could
control um and I know it's not suitable
for everybody who can't access the
internet but maybe if we have a
telephone number and a reference number
you can program into the telephone
number as you make a phone call so you
know the person at the end of the phone
call is going to know who you are where
your residence is and what what you're
going to be issued rather than going
through system as it is which by the
time you've got to speak to somebody you
probably forgotten what You' phoned for
so these sort of things a degree of
control I'd like to see um but finally I
do realize we've had problems in the
past but we are making progress
and it's taken me three and a half years
to actually get a repair done this year
I've had some repairs done so we we've
been in a slow burner but at least we're
finally starting to see some progress so
thank you
thank you um councelor Smith thanks
chair um yeah David indicated that
you're looking at it already but could
we recommend that we prioritize taking
contracts in
house
um
please councilor
Pratt
yeah I'll try and make this very brief
um so I was just um speaking earlier um
about uh using Talent from from other
groups and working across um different
departments um say like with um the um
communities and and with um planning um
to bring about um improvements in our in
our um Council housing
stock um you know we all know that
there's a lot of financial presses and
there's no money for building loads of
new Council houses but this was is
really the single biggest thing we could
do to make a massive difference one of
one of the one of the backlogs is is
getting data to to find out you
know where where that housing need is
it's quite expensive for Parish councils
to go to Community Action suffk and pay
for the survey and it's quite a
long-winded process um I've been told by
some that you know the surveys are quite
lengthy um
I I know that within our people and
place team that um there have been
efforts to try and streamline um things
like housing needs surveys um for the
purposes of um informing people in place
plans but could we do something to to
make it more effective and in-house um
to make it easier to to carry out these
surveys and get that data um to find out
where we we could do with some more
Council
housing working across um different
teams thank you very much um so we we do
have a lot of recommendations there and
we need we do need to remind ourselves
that these recommendations will go to
cabinet and be looked at um we're not
making recommendations directly to the
department now we're going through the
cabinet and they may cut them down or
uh you know the if we if we do a too
many recommendations it might dilute the
recommendations we make but what we'll
do now is we'll just stop for five
minutes while um we we get together the
exact wording of the recommendations how
we want it and then um we'll um discuss
any recommendations we need to tweak or
make sure that they're they're
acceptable to the group or remove
um and then we'll get back to it so um
councelor
grandon in the process are we checking
with the officers that that they're
workable feasible or do you think that's
not yeah I think if we can yeah there's
um if we'd look at um maybe having a
couple of officers in that conversation
to um to make sure that we're
not asking them to do something they're
already doing or or whatever ever but um
yeah so we'll have five minutes um now
um I do wonder if um officers not
involved in that process could leave and
um I'm not quite sure you you know who
you are but I will say thank you so much
for coming in today and it's been quite
a heavy questioning session but um the
work you do is fantastic and it's very
difficult on the um resources you have
and the sheer amount of work that you're
all doing individually to um you know to
um do it but you do do a fantastic job
and thank you for that and um yeah if um
we could just have a couple um stay
behind thank
you
okay thank you very much you're welcome
back um I will now ask the governance
officer to um read out the
recommendations please thank you chair I
think it's going to be me actually um so
we have a long list so I'll read them
slowly and then um we can come back to
any that you're not sure about so um the
recommendation is that councelor be
asked to consider the following um
recommendation s the first one is to
reduce the time scales for the stock
conditions
uded to reconsider the use of In-House
occupational therapists to identify what
is really affordable in the private
Market to various demographics to
determine the most appropriate tenur to
secure and
deliver a rag status to be taken and
used in the report and more focus on
Associated risks of
delivery cabinet be asked to make sure
that there is a clear refocus on housing
and to ensure there is support to
achieve the housing needs of our
residents members to have as much
involvement as possible and where
possible open sessions with all members
invited um the number of dwellings with
outstanding planning permission and the
situation of the houses where they're
not being built to be
established identify those people who
are most vulnerable so that we can
consider designing services around their
needs look at the communications red
downsizing and to investigate private
landlords before we work with them and
then finally reconsider the means in
which data is collected in support of
community-led
housing hopefully I've captured
everything councelor
Pearson could I have the last three
repeated please pardon could I have the
last three repeated last repeated so
look at the communications red
downsizing investigate private landlords
before we work with them and then
reconsider the means in which data is
collected in support of community-led
housing C
scar councilor scar uh yeah person I'm
happy with all of those because I think
that puts what we've said very
succinctly but um recommendations 3.2
that we had in the original paper um I
think it's still worth repeating sport
the
aims yes so chair I can just read that
out so the so and then we get so once
we've done that and we'll call that 3.1
with loads of um app uh appes and then
3.2 the overview scrutiny support the
Strategic aims of the homes and housing
strategy ensuring the delivery plan is
reflective of the current challenges
facing the housing sector whilst
continuing to deliver the aim set out in
the homes and housing
strategy thank you and councilor scoff
would you propose that
um I'm happy to propose them on block Mr
chair yeah thank you um are there
any councilor Carter uh just regards um
we mentioned previously about improving
the two-way communication between
counsil the talant and I don't know if
there's any way we can add that into a
recommendation or just take it as noted
what was mentioned in the
meeting it wasn't read out as a
recommendation so I don't know if it's
just for not points just that point just
for noted or is
it
um yes just to Ure that tenants do have
the feedback that when they raise a
issue that is definitely being seen go
back
so
okay okay thank you having that as a
separate recomendation we just I I think
if I think if you're going to be redoing
it it's it's this is about added value
we're not adding value if you're already
doing it councelor scaf do you agree
with that as the proposal yeah okay um
councelor
grandon thank you um I mean one thing I
just wondered whether it can maybe be
that those points be put up on the board
or sent to us because it's quite so much
to to take in with just being read but
we'll try and do that thank you um one
of the points I'd like to make is
regarding the
downsizing um point that just seemed to
concentrate on
Communications but is it only
Communications that we feel needs to be
looked at regarding that um you know do
we do we maybe want to look
at you know what we're up the strategy
or or what's being offered or whatever
um perhaps we can take it as a subject
and look at it you know as a whole yeah
I mean you know is it because that's if
it's just a matter of are we looking at
are we emailing them more you know it's
not just the communications I think that
needs to ex be examined on that aspect
chair would it work if I put look at the
communications and process red
downsizing councelor
scarf yeah
okay um and then um the other point I
wanted to say is I didn't notice
anything there regarding sort of
proactively assisting older people if
they have a problem um did was there one
there was quite hard to CH sorry that
was the identifying those people who are
most vulnerable so that we consider
designing services around their needs so
that was what we need to do um is find
out who those people are and then look
at what we can do to provide the
services around that so they do get
their additional support and that is
something that the housing team are
looking at so that's why it's worded
like that so it's the most vulnerable
people okay can can we have the word
proactive somewhere in because then that
sort of
changes how you deal with it we can put
so that we proactively consider thank
you
um councelor row did you have sorry did
you have your hand up you might not have
done um no I
didn't um does anybody else want we
we're still missing a second for this um
councelor
Wyman um is all possible to share
it how we are we able to get that up on
the board because it I think it would be
really
useful um I don't think we can get it up
on the screens chair but I can circulate
those to all members now just before the
vote it's quite hard to with so many
thank we we won't be able to have that
on the um it TR um or the modern. goov
sorry I think it's too long no no it is
it's going to take too much time so um
are you sending an email to um yes yeah
if you look at your um emails there
should be a email coming through with
those recommendations on and then um if
there's no I'll give everyone a chance
to look at them and if there's no
problem we'll go to the vote
please
has everyone received
that thank
you councelor
Smith thanks can I can I just ask number
five the clear refocus on housing what's
the context of that isn't
that what we here for that was the need
to make sure that cabinet you know they
refocus and is a clear
priority
thanks what we'll do is we'll start the
vote now but please take your time to
read but um you if you could vote when
you finished reading thank
you
um in these recommendations we haven't
added the bit for to look at
downsizing um it still says
Communications relating to downside and
do we um could we just have
we'll just do that yeah
verbally yeah the so that will be look
at communications and the process of
downsizing it's as simple as that
yeah
yeah the counc rean um chair if I may um
I have for I have to leave to go to
another meeting but I just wanted to say
if I may thanks to the um members of the
committee because I think the
questioning has been really good and
it's really good to see such involvement
from everybody on the Comm committee and
also thanks very much to the officers
for um all of their efforts with this
and um just to mention that on one of
those
recommendations um we very much have as
a cabinet at mids suffk and I'm sure bab
was the same very much have a focus on
housing because there's a lots of things
we want to be doing there so um that'll
certainly that is already happening as
it were but I appreciate you all put it
into your recommendations here but we
are certainly focusing on on housing the
moment but thank you very much chair
thanks to everybody for your um
involvement today thanks yeah and thank
you councelor eburn for attending the
meeting and standing in um for two
different portfolio holders on two
different councils and being so
useful um handling a portfolio that's
not your own which which is incredible
we're really pleased to have you here
and thank you very
much
councelor Smith and councel PE um I'm
still waiting for your votes
on hang on it's just counselor Smith now
it's coming through okay thank
you um chair since councel Riley's left
we have only 11 votes in for this and
that's 11 votes for so it's your thank
you so that's
carried um so we'll go through the last
part of the meeting I I will tell you at
this point I I don't think we should do
the training after this because I think
this meeting's taken a long time and we
it's not time sensitive so we'll um
we'll um do that another time when we
when we can thank you so um item eight
the forthcoming decisions list um do
members have any comments on
that it's for noting so with no um
comments we'll move on to um item nine
which is the action tracker um
do councelor McLaren sorry chair I just
I'm just
councelor valy is gone I'm just mindful
of that that it keeps raising the thing
about C Lane can we have an information
bulletin on
that thank you chair um so this is
technically for the next item Vi work
plan
um but I'll take that question now um I
did take away councilor Riley's request
for an information bulletin on corks
Lane um I went to a senior leadership
meeting last week to discuss how this
would be most appropriately brought up
um councelor Riley is on the board for
corks Lane you have to forg me I don't
remember what the name is for
it is the director of
the he's the director of the the holding
company so um and it was due to be
discussed at that meeting so he would
have been updated then I know but you I
just trying to preempt any question
SE okay so yeah and we'll note that on
the um bab work plan please um so um
then so the action tracker are there any
questions or comments on the action
tracker so that that's also for noting
so um thank you um right so the number
10 is the bab over overview and scrutiny
work plan any comments from Baba
members
no thank you and then the mids suffer AV
and scrutiny plan and any
comments right well thank you very much
and that concludes the meeting so um our
next um meeting me will be held on the
20th of November um at
9:30 a.m. is that the um one where we're
going out to the
um um
no when are we doing the um social
housing
um um so members we do have a scrutiny
tour for um social housing an upcoming
social housing item that should be next
Tuesday um on the 31st at half n so yeah
so please get that in the it should be
in your Diaries already um but yeah
thank you very much and I'll close the
meeting